[Musique]
le port de plaisance de la chine s'est
jetée s'étend sur 4 hectares dans le sud
ouest de montréal
450 bateaux ils sont amarrés cet été en
matière de capacité d'accueil
c'est la plus grande marina du québec ex
aequo à l'excellent vieux longueuil
depuis trois ans dominique marie josée
et raphaël passent leurs étés ici
mais ce pourrait être le dernier cette
famille de terrebonne a été averti le 8
juillet que la marina fermera ses portes
à la fin de la saison
jusqu'à ce que je sais c'est le site
changera bientôt de vocation pour
devenir un parc riverain
les travaux s'étaleront jusqu'en 2025 on
est parti avec une esquisse parce qu'il
fallait bien partir avec quelque chose
et on est parti avec un engagement
depuis devenu millions alors je me
doutais qu'ils vivent un million on note
qu'au faire quelque chose de bien que
les plaisanciers qui n'ont pas été
consultés en amont sont loin de la
trouver drôle
ils ont mis sur pied une association un
site web une page facebook et ils
promettent de se battre deux pétitions
ont été lancées l'une d'elles a déjà
recueilli près de 3000 noms ils n'ont
que deux mille deux cent cinquante
places à quai au québec principalement
dans la grande région métropolitaine
donc pour nous on vient de créer en se
faisant 450 orphelins qui n'auront pas
de place pour mettre leurs bateaux à
quai pour la prochaine saison lui
plaisant s'ils font notamment valoir
l'aspect patrimonial de la marina qui
existe depuis presque cent ans
l'administration de projet montréal
portent cependant quelques nuances
car depuis sa création en 1927 le port
de plaisance de la chaîne a changé
d'emplacement de nom et de propriétaire
autrefois privé le heroes couailhac club
a fait faillite en 1995 il doit sa
survie à l'ancienne ville de lachine
ces installations des six titres est
aujourd'hui un investissement colossal
en une fosse septique qui
malheureusement tombe en ruine ont un
vieux tech à essence parce qu'on vende
l'essence 300 millilitres par était
alors tout ça est en fin de vie les
coûts de remettre ça en ordre les
stationnements
les chemins la route sa s'élève à tous
de 16 millions alors on s'est dit mais
est ce qu'on va mettre 16.5 millions
pour 400 personnes 450 les anciens la
mairesse rêve plutôt d'aménager une aire
de baignade sur le site comme au début
du siècle dernier
elle veut aussi faire plus de place au
club de voile de canaux de kayak et
d'aviron point de vue bâtiment ça laisse
un peu à désirer
on est très à l'étroit on doit avoir des
bateaux qui sont stockés dehors ce qu'on
a plus de place à l'intérieur
donc on est très limitée en termes de
bâtiments le projet prévoit également le
maintien du club des pêcheurs
une autre petite marina de la chine qui
accueille une cinquantaine de bateaux à
moteur
elle pourrait être agrandi mais il
serait illusoire de penser qu'elle
pourrait accueillir 450 embarcations
supplémentaires les plaisanciers cherche
donc une solution un compromis pour que
tous puissent continuer à cohabiter
on est prêt à faire des certaines
concessions pour pouvoir conserver la
marine a donc si ça signifie de devoir
relocaliser certains quais de faire plus
d espace
on est prêt à négocier pour voir qu'est
ce qu'ils en aient les propriétaires de
bateaux rencontreront sous peu
l'administration plantes pour lui
présenter leurs arguments mais à moins
d'un revirement majeur
les plaisanciers devront se résoudre à
quitter la marina au dedans si le 15
octobre
l'été prochain le panorama pourrait donc
être fort différent dans le vieux
lachine
[Musique]